did you know that net arose 100 type
Guan Yin Bodhisattva has at least 96
other hand maneuvers that we simply did
not get to see in the series one of
which is the 100 pound which activates
all of the arms simultaneously and has
them click that subscribe button so that
network can receive regular Hunter
hunter content uploaded straight into
his YouTube feed a very powerful attack
indeed hello and welcome to the new
world review your source for everything
anime and manga and today it's time to
look into a lurking legend of hunter
hunter a man with an unparalleled legacy
and who is sure to have a profound
impact on the series beyond nattara
so if you are an anime only fan you'll
probably have twigged a part of his name
because yes beyond is the son of the
former chairman of the hunter
Association Issac Network which you can
probably also tell by the strong
resemblance beyond bears to his father
because the network LAN seems to have
very distinctive facial features now if
you're wondering why we haven't
discovered that such an important figure
had a son much much sooner in the series
well you're not alone because even
though zodiacs were not aware of beyonds
existence before it was publicly
revealed by King now so be Hui Goro of
the cockin Empire and it just goes to
show that this world is so expansive
that you can never be sure what's lying
in wait out there I mean we've traveled
all over the human realm and in theory
we should have a good grasp of the top
hunters and end users but then all of a
sudden a man whose name clearly implies
that he may be even more powerful than
Isaac networked himself just appears out
of nowhere and people might say that the
claims about his power is a bit of a
stretch especially since we have seen
the full extent of what Isaac was
capable of so how could his brat even
come close to rivaling that well I have
to say that yes it is entirely possible
because we don't have a solid answer of
exactly how old beyond is because
remember netra himself is well over 100
years old so for all we know beyond
could be in his 70s 80s 90s or even 100
himself having lived a long and fruitful
life mastering the use of Nan and being
in a stage of his life that much more
reflects net Horus Prime than his
elderly engagement against marijuana in
fact during the Chimera antic Isaac even
went so far as to state that his time at
the top of Nan mastery had long since
passed which does imply that there is a
whole new generation of men users
achieving that pinnacle and I don't say
why beyond could not be one of them
especially given his impressive pedigree
but with that in mind how exactly does
beyond fit into the story going forward
well beyond is a figure intrinsically
linked to the dark on Tennant and in
fact he is the primary driving force
behind the entire endeavor becoming the
catalyst for at least 3 diff
groups to commence a voyage to that
destination being the [ __ ] in Empire a
hunter Association and his own personal
expedition team which has some pretty
well-known figures amongst it
now as for exactly why beyond is focused
on getting to the dark continent we can
only speculate at this stage however
very very interesting Lee it should be
brought up right here and now the beyond
has actually been to the dark continent
once already and this expedition
occurred at least fifty years ago when
beyond was hired by the v5 the ruling
nations of the human realm as one of
their experts in regards to the Dark
Continent and they in secret land a
sneaky expedition and I guess when I say
in secret all of the v5 nations were in
on it but they neglected to tell the
hunter Association because at that time
Isaac Metro had warned them against it
and had even lobbied to forbid all
travel to the landmass and this is
because Isaac had first-hand experience
of the Dark Continent having ventured
there not only once but twice and having
survived to tell the tale on both
occasions and of course one of these
trips was unofficial and unrecorded with
his reasoning for embarking being rather
selfish search for an ultimate opponent
to fight this voyage was conducted with
his two friends exotic and Lynn hors
d'oeuvre and as for the recorded trip we
don't have any more details on that but
this made Isaac effectively the world's
most prominent expert on the Dark
Continent not including Don freaks of
course and so he exerted profound
influence even forbidding the hunter
Association to venture there but beyond
and the v5 conducted a secret expedition
there anyway landing on the southern
shore of Lake Mobius and they were
allegedly in search of metallian a
mysterious alchemical plant that would
have provided some sort of exceptional
benefit to humanity however just as with
most previous expeditions to the Dark
Continent this party would end up
failing in their tasks and becoming
decimated to the point where only six
survivors including beyond returned
safely and actually one of them didn't
return safely at all because as
punishment the guide constraint what is
now known as one of the five threats
upon the group forcing them to take back
the ZURB eye disease which is also known
as the immortality disease that had
infected and killed a large majority of
the expedition group although there was
one member who was still held in
captivity with the disease having cast a
torturous immortality upon him and after
this expedition returned Isaac was a bit
more forceful in his attitude to the
Dark Continent given that his son's
efforts had brought back an
extinction-level threat to humanity as
such Isaac actively forbade his son
beyond from ever traveling there until
after his death
Isaac's death that is not beyond and
exactly why beyond would honor this is
unknown but he does appear to have kept
his word and it
wasn't until Isaac Metro passed away
during his battle with the Chimera ant
King Mero am that filmed once again
put his plan into motion to visit the
continent although it's not as if he
spent this time doing nothing just
waiting for this moment as bill needed
to find a new benefactor to achieve his
goal and knowing that neither the hunter
Association nor the v5 would cooperate
this time around beyond set his sights
on the cocking Empire telling its ruler
nasibi about the great benefits of the
Dark Continent and what they could offer
his kingdom and eventually Mouse we took
beyond words to heart and decided that
he would not only set sail to the
landmass but actively attempt to settle
on the Dark Continent taking with him
the entire Kotkin royal family as well
as further 200,000 personnel and of
course in this effort
NASA be named beyond as his guide to the
continent it should be said that this is
but one threat of beyonds master plan
though he's quite a conniving fellow
really and clearly has his sights set on
his own personal goals having formed his
own secret expedition team and
apparently this team began to be formed
roughly half a century ago so almost
immediately after beyonds first failed
voyage and it currently consists of
around 25 temporary hunters all of whom
are experts in a particular field
necessary for survival as well as 11
mercenaries and not only that but for
quite some time the team's
second-in-command was one para stand
hill the former vice chairman of the
hunter Association and in fact the core
reason why power stand became a hunter
in the first place and sought power
amongst the Institute was so that he
could adequately prepare for this voyage
meanwhile in the modern day this team
has had an unexpected addition being
Jing freaks a former member of the
zodiacs within the hunter Association
now to the best of our knowledge at the
time of this recording Jing and Beyond
have never met but Jing kind of forced
his way onto the expedition team
regardless offering very very handsome
payment to its members as well as a
wealth of information published by Don
freaks during this time it also became
clear that beyond had not been so
forthright in regards to giving out
details about the continent itself
because while he offered 1.5 billion
Genny to any member who stepped foot
there he does appear to have neglected
to tell them about the extreme dangers
and overwhelming possibility of death or
even worse actually because quite a few
Dark Continent creatures have abilities
that force humans into a sort of eternal
state of torture such as the zoo by
disease which beyond has first-hand
experience with now all of this is not
to say the peons actions were not
predicted because Isaac anticipating his
death recorded a video message for the
hunter Association informing them of
beyond and his ambitions and further
or even charging them with the task to
explore the dark continent before beyond
and acquires something of great use to
humanity although after hearing of the
car cane Empire's ambitions the
Association received a request from the
v5 to hunt and capture beyond however
beyond anticipated this and turned
himself in to the Association before
they would have the chance to do so and
just as he had done successfully thus
far he also put himself in a position to
manipulate the Association into
facilitating his goals as he correctly
predicted that the v5 Nations would come
to support the endeavors of the carking
Empire which not only did they but they
even incorporated the Empire into their
group becoming the v6 although beyond
still remained effectively a prisoner of
the hunter Association and is currently
incarcerated aboard the black whale one
being guarded by three members of the
zodiacs one of which being siyou has
been identified as a spy working with
beyonds expedition team quite notably
though we also have confirmation that
beyond honestly knows nothing about a
spy within the zodiacs so this would
appear to be a plot formed purely by
parastone but as of right now the plan
is to go above the cocking empires head
and drop them off at a nother landmass
known as the new continent after which
point beyond the hunter Association and
select members of the previous v5
nations will proceed to the actual dark
continent and at the moment beyond seems
perfectly content with this in fact he
is in one of the best possible
situations being escorted under high
guard to exactly the location that he
desires to be in while all the chaos of
the succession war is playing out around
him now what isn't clear at this stage
is exactly what has become of his
expedition team none of them have been
sighted at both blackwell one so they
may have embarked via a different ship
or have another method entirely that or
they're hiding aboard the black whale as
many others are but whatever the case
beyond is currently involved in more of
a waiting game and he doesn't care
whatsoever for anything happening around
him he has a very singular focus on
returning to the site of disaster and
this drive is pretty terrifying because
beyond goal while unknown is obviously
starkly different from everyone else who
wishes to travel there for example most
individuals or countries dream of
finding a rare asset to humanity that
would revolutionize the world as well as
solidify their own personal power or in
the case of Jing freaks he seems more
genuinely curious than anything but
beyond on the other hand well he seems
to know exactly what he's looking for
and it gives off some very sinister
overtones it's something that I feel
Isaac had a decent idea of as well which
is why he went to the effort of
recording that video for the Association
warning them of beyond and trying to get
their full force involved so this guy to
me is a ticking time bomb of villainy on
a vessel that contains antagonists like
Hisoka the Phantom troop in Surat Nick
beyond is the person who probably
terrifies me the most and I think the
reasons why I'm going to become very
apparent when his half-a-century plan
comes to fruition and he finds himself
let loose on the Dark Continent
and that pretty much does it for beyond
netter Oh for now anyway if you enjoyed
this video and the content this channel
produce in general then please do
consider donating to the new world of
view patreon because the support of all
the amazing people is what continues to
make this channel possible and if
patreon isn't quite your style then
please do leave this video a like share
or subscribe because it also helps
support this channel an incredible
amount and if you'd like to join the fun
at any time then please do head over to
my discord server where a wide array of
shenanigan ray takes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
your thoughts on beyond network this has
been the new Walt review and I'll see
you next time
[Music]
how would you imagine a return for gone
that makes it satisfying and fair so
from my perspective if Gahan does return
to the story the one thing I don't want
for him is to be able to use nan again
or at least not to the extent that he
was previously able to I think that
doing so would take away a huge part of
the dramatic sacrifice that was required
to beat an ephah Peto and I really like
that even though he was restored by
nanika that this is a decision that he
is going to have to live with
permanently
so if gone does need to be involved in
the future for example if any of the
Jireh stuff comes to fruition and I'd
like to see him handle it without the
use of nen I think it would be a cool
way to book in the series because he
started out not knowing it and I just
don't want the Val he made in the
chimera ant are to become narrative Lea
undercut why did you choose the name new
world review alright nice question so if
you're a one piece fan and it's probably
pretty obvious why I chose this name and
I'll say right here that my other
channel is called grand line review the
grand line being the location of the
world where the bulk of the one piece
story takes place and the second half of
the grand line is called the new world
so when I wanted to make a second
channel it just made the Matic sense to
escalate from grand line review into the
new world view although I am
legitimately thinking of seeing if we
could change it to the nan world review
although that would require all sorts of
rebranding efforts on my part so I'll be
honest it will more than likely just
remain you Walter view